the next issue natural gas fracking he
is routine you can pull it up right here
a thousand different quotes of joe biden
in the primary
are you willing to sacrifice some of
that blue-collar growth if it means
putting you know tens of thousands maybe
even hundred thousands of blue-collar
workers out of a job
what does joe biden's the answer is yes
and but but if you talk to the media
well
joe biden doesn't want to ban fracking
i'm like but
are you are you just saying what he's
saying because he's saying it now
or are you actually listening just
because he's saying it now doesn't mean
that it's true look well look at the
things that he said in the past
here's the important thing about the
whole defund the police conversation
i'm looking at these stories and they're
doing a fact check did joe biden and
they say well while joe biden did say he
was talking about relocating funds
his larger platform i don't care about
his larger platform you know why because
if joe biden's going to sit down with an
activist and tell them whatever they
want to hear i don't know
what he's talking about i don't know
what he wants to do when donald trump's
like i'm going to build a big beautiful
wall from sea to shining sea
30 feet concrete and then he actually
prototyped it i'm like this dude's nuts
but this is actually really funny so
trump ends up settling for
you know bollard fencing in select areas
reinforcing key areas
and they mock him for it and i'm like
but it was because he consulted with the
actual immigration experts who said we
need to be able to see through it anyone
oh so we can't do concrete no we need to
see on the other side
oh okay and then what did they do they
reinforced the key areas because of
budgeting issues
they they reduced a lot of the
trafficking and smuggling he got what he
wanted done i believed trump that he
really wanted to do it
i think he really wanted a big concrete
wall when i hear joe biden
he what did he say he's like moratorium
on my deportations decriminalized border
crossings he's back and forth 50 million
taxpayers
health care for for illegal immigrants
and by the way i just want to put this
to rest
right now i want people to come to this
country
legal immigration is great but
you know what liberals do is they
conflate they try to make republicans as
if we're anti-immigrant they conflate
illegal
immigration with legal immigration it's
not true we
want diversity here in this country
right we want unity
through that diversity we just want a
structure
that people can use to come here legally
and safely because
right now there is a tidal wave of human
suffering
at the southern border you want to send
you know one of your liberal journalist
friends on a trip send them down there
they won't do it well i mean you know
it's look
uh i donald trump gave a speech years
ago
where he was like you see what's going
on last night in sweden it's crazy blah
blah
blah
and it became this you do a pretty good
trump do you do you do a pretty good
trumpet
you should throw yourself into it
completely i do sometimes i
can do some pretty good impersonations
across the board yeah across the board
yeah yeah yeah totally i could do a
really good golem from lord of the rings
too
anyway the the point is he said last
night in sweden
this became a huge news story where
they're like you know what happened in
sweden nothing happened in sweden what
trump meant was
last night on fox news they did this
documentary on sweden
and so he's just speaking off the coffee
speaking really quickly and they take
everything he says literally
so i decided i'm gonna go to sweden so
me and a friend my friend emily who is
now doing a lot of the
scnr reporting from one of my other
companies we decided
let's fly to sweden and let's go around
and film and interview people and see if
it's really as bad as many of these
people are saying
we i ended up getting inundated with a
bunch of leftist journalists saying
don't do it don't go we i ended up
raising like eight grand
in a day because a bunch of
conservatives were like go do it we want
to see a journalist actually go and
cover it because i was like i'll go i'll
i'll totally go i'll
cover what explain how sweden just like
this idea that
there was this idea that immigration had
caused rampant crime in sweden and
asylum yes
yes oh right right i got it i understand
so i was like i'll go check it out
right i ended up raising uh a total like
at the end of the whole trip like 20
grand or something throughout the trip
people were donating
but i got all these leftist journalists
dming me people i used to work with
saying don't do it don't go
i had i used to work for vice right vice
would go
on the ground in these countries they
got a vice published documentary from
isis territory
and i got guys from vice hitting up
saying tim don't go to sweden and i'm
like
what do you mean like this i literally
worked with you guys like
two years ago we used to do this all the
time i'm doing literally what we always
do no no
it's a lie these journalists not only
don't want to go there
they want to stop other people from
going there they don't want you to go
there and film the truth and say here's
what's happening on southern border
they want the narrative that they can
use i don't know why because i
i can't imagine they're gaining anything
from it it's like a feel-good
tribal thing i guess well here's here's
the thing so this is i talked to
some of the union leadership i feel like
i was the first republican to show up to
the
union you know afl-cio board you know
got
the the building trades there and uh the
government union guys and the fl cio
board and that's what i tried to explain
to a lot of the building trades guys is
that not only does illegal immigration
undercut your wages
and make it more difficult for you to
find a job what the pro
act does if you look at the pro act
which is a
did you hear joe biden and conor lamb
talk about it all the time it's going to
be the future and the future of union
membership here in this country
well the pro act affords union
protection to illegal immigrants
wow so every you know the lion's share
of economic experts in this country will
say
that the pro act be a wet blanket on the
economy right
um while simultaneously flooding union
halls
with illegal immigrants that are all of
a sudden afforded
legal protections legal protections what
do you think is that that's going to do
to your members your already existing
members who are having trouble finding a
job is going to undermine their ability
to make a living
yet democrats push the pro act as if
it's pro-union it's not pro-union it
actually flies in the face of what davis
bacon was created to protect
and so i take this message to the rank
and foul union guys that it is by and
large not good for them because part of
my job
is to protect their ability to earn a
living and put food on the table for
their family
and i get criticized for it because i i
part of me feels like the narrative
is is king right and the idea that the
democrat party
is the party of unions i it's i don't
know that that's
the building trades guys it used to be
did you see what happened when they
proposed the green new deal
and the i think was the afl-cio came out
and like threw up in their mouths when
they read it
it was going to eliminate the energy
sector jobs it's gonna i think it was
the aflci i'm not sure but
a bunch of these unions were like whoa
whoa whoa you're straight up saying
you're gonna
shut our jobs down why would we support
that well that's that's what
when i say pennsylvanians have short
memories this is what they see they
don't want to lose those jobs you know
oil and natural gas industry in
pennsylvania is a centerpiece of our
economy
did you see what hillary clinton said
was one of her biggest regrets in the
2016 campaign i think it
may have been her biggest regret when
she said that we were going to shut down
all these coal jobs oh
yeah well joe biden essentially said the
same thing exactly he said yep he said
if you can go down in a mine shaft
you can learn to code wait he actually
said learn the code
i'm pretty sure he said yeah if you have
if you can go down three thousand foot
into mine shaft you can learn to code
i look it up i i look it up
yeah there it is there it is right wow
sheesh yeah yeah it tells coal miners to
learn the code
oh sean sean's a propagandist no i'm not
he said it
um and so here you know
these jobs you know i come from my
grandfather
who's a second father to me for god's
sake was a union a lifelong union
democrat
these jobs are legacy jobs to these
people their father was a coal miner
their father's father was a coal miner
and all of a sudden you have a
politician
i mean who was supposed to be elected by
the people to prote
to protect and advocate for them saying
you know what yeah
this legacy you care you just heard the
code bro
dude it's like this uh look i got to
show this video man
this video um i don't think i'm going to
play it but
this guy had his family's business his
parents started this business they
burned it to the ground
and these these these people who are
marching around destroying these things
who get this defense from democrats who
pretend like it's a peaceful march and
they need to protect them
don't understand they're not just
they're not just attacking this guy it's
his legacy
it's more than his dream for his kids
you know
i was looking at buildings i'm trying to
expand the business you know what we've
got uh some big plans we're about to do
it's awesome i'm really excited a
million subscribers
yeah i hit a million subscribers but i
do have multiple channels so it's like
you know it's it's more
but i'm looking i was i went to this one
building and there was a guy there who
was like in his 80s and he wanted to
sell it
and i asked him i was like you know why
you want to sell it he didn't have any
kids it actually made me feel really sad
he built this building over decades as
his building expanded
like a makeshift jigsaw puzzle just
pulling on pieces
and i told him i was like i want you to
just record a story and tell the story
about how you built this and like what
the building was how it came to be just
like give me 10 minutes
he didn't want to do it i don't i don't
think he has to
but to me i i take value i i i really
value the accomplishments of humanity
where we've come from where we're going
i think about the idea that we're
standing on shoulder
the shoulders of giants i say that all
the time i agree completely and and i
you know look i go to new york
you see all these bridges over the
hudson over the you know
i think it's is that no it's the east
river not the hudson tunnels
well they have some bridges but you see
all these bridges i have no idea how
they got there
i woke up one day and walked in and i
can walk across this river this big
bridge people are skating out they have
no idea
the the blood sweat and tears that went
in to making sure that they would have
shade you know you know the saying you
you plant a tree whose shade you know
you'll never sleep
you'll never get to sit under these like
so many people millions of people
just woke up one day with the brooklyn
bridge they didn't have to build it
no work went into it they just one day
have it and it's just their form that's
that's legacy
so when you see these the to go back to
the coal miners to being to being told
learn to code
it's like joe biden may as well have
burned down their family business
that everything that was there i
couldn't imagine
i couldn't imagine someone you know here
here's what your family is here's what
your family's done here's the history
here's what you're proud of screw it go
be a computer programmer in new york
that's that's exactly what he's saying
yeah that's exactly what he's saying you
know what's really crazy about this
learn to code thing
it was a meme and it got conservatives
banned on social media i know
i know i mean and there's joe biden out
there telling you i didn't even know joe
biden said then this was this is
but this is what's crazy about this is
this story is from uh when is it from
the hill
2019 yes he said it on the campaign
trail december
it's from it's from last december the
learn to code thing i mean
uh we're gonna phase out he also says
we're gonna phase out all fossil fuels
you know
so december 31st 2019 yes
the learn to code was it wasn't the
learn to code ban fiasco like way before
that
yes wow wow dude talk about
nightmarishly out of touch
that creeps me out i mean you wouldn't
believe the things that he says
but i mean people would at this point
people don't people don't believe it you
know
i again this is why this is why
fundraising is so important
because the media should be telling
people this but the media does not
like well you would think the media in
western pennsylvania would report on
this given that tens of thousands of
people work in this industry
they might want to know that this is
these are the positions that joe biden
espouses
you know you the fact that aoc is now
conor lamb's boss
on this energy environmental task force
is kind of relevant kamala harris she
supports the green new deal
she co-wrote it oh there you go she
co-wrote the bill
this is it's just look when
aoc first got elected the first thing i
did was i laughed
these establishment democrats getting
come up into these young upstarts
kicking them out i'm like good
they sit around they get elected they do
nothing so you know what
he did you know uh joe crowley he he
took he was uh he was arrogant and he
lost for it so i laughed
i looked at a lot of her policy
positions and i'm like does a decent
amount actually agree with
you know prison reform and and you know
some other things
when the green new deal was first being
talked about it was framed in such a way
that i thought was awesome
here's what they did they said would you
support government investment
into green technologies to help offset
carbon emissions
86 of people were like yeah of course
like look if the government's
you know got uh money for grants and
these programs it sounds like it's a
good idea
so when the green new deal is first
announced it's like the idea is to
repair our infrastructure and develop
new technologies and green technologies
to to you know
help make our country more energy
independent and efficient i'm like that
sounds great
and then she released it and i was i was
like
what is this garbage money for people
unwilling to work
farting cows getting rid of planes no
planes no meat but
the whole second page or at least a
large portion of it was talking about
racial equity payments
and i'm like what does that have to do
with developing new technology to
improve the lives of americans
the greatest look i mean the green new
deal is obviously insane
okay it just is as as a policy proposal
as a standalone policy proposal
it's insane it's not reality again my
my position on energy is all of the
above you know where we can use
renewables
let's do it let's invest in it nuclear
energy nuclear energy is also something
that we have to look at
uh but you want a case study in a
country migrating
exclusively to renewable energy
sources is germany look at what happened
in germany
whatever their energy costs skyrocketed
it was a disaster the people that people
said no more
and and they and they've had to sort of
transition from renewable energy sources
to
now natural gas you see what happened in
france when they said
we're going to impose a tax on on gas
so oh there was a borderland people were
like there was a right that's right for
like two years
there was a revolt i that that kind of
bums me out i don't like the idea that
you know we we as a human civilization
need to progress we need to do better
and
you know we we get stuck and it's
if you've ever been on a hydraulic
fracturing rig i see where you're going
with this it is it is like
this is like star trek enterprise type
stuff
like when you talk about like getting
better you know horizontal drilling
the way you got to go like come out to
western pennsylvania we'll go take a
tour of one it'll blow your mind how
precise they are
some of these some of these companies
like penn energy resources has a zero
methane
tolerance right methane oh methane is
bad and it is right yeah
they're so precise they they tolerate
zero methane
emissions you know and and they're so
advanced and it was precisely that
market-based innovation right that has
allowed us to
be a leader in in decreasing our carbon
emissions right
um and every day i mean so i say all
this to say
it's market-based innovation that will
lead the way to
more cleaner and more renewable energy
sources not government monopolies but
that's what i and
yeah that was my point well i co-opted
your point yeah yeah yeah yeah
no the the general idea is that we we we
develop this technology
and then the government wants to make
sure
that it's easier
to just keep everything frozen than it
is to actually allow
the market to change with new
technologies and new development i think
there's there's there's obviously
extreme ends we can't just have
you know archaic jobs because people are
like the job is more important than
innovation
and we can't have learn to code there's
got to be
you know competitive gradual change to
develop new technologies
one of the biggest challenges i see
though nuclear energy seems very
promising
it is one of the highest energy return
on energy investments it's it's clean
zero carbon emissions boom and the left
opposes it
i i think i think they oppose it just
because it gets a bad rap
i mean you know you watch something so
my dad works in nuclear energy he's like
one of the smartest guys i've ever met
he's amazing
um but he like i like watch chernobyl
and i'm like oh man this is so great dad
i love this and he was like offended
when he watched it
he's like this is this is not how
nuclear energy works so this is why this
is why nuclear energy gets a bad rap
because
it's sort of yeah i mean chernobyl was
obviously a catastrophe it was a
disaster i mean the human
there was human error i mean all sorts
of bad things happen but
you know and i'm certainly not trying to
just brush that off right
um but the the nuclear energy there
are all nuclear navy right that we've
had in this country for a long time
there's not been one single incident
not a single incident since since the
inception of our all nuclear navy
because in the united states we've got a
real great system of checks and balances
uh but when you talk to a lot of the the
energy executives and say in western
pennsylvania that are that are
in natural gas it's a simple dollars and
cents issues for them you know they say
like well
i just can't why build a nuclear power
plant where there are so many government
regulations that you have to jump
through it's a
multi-billion dollar investment when you
can just you know
invest in natural gas it's exponentially
cheaper kind of what i was trying to get
at too is is
the government is impeding instead of
i guess appropriate refereeing you know
nuclear energy
is is being demonized there are
a lot of democrats progressives they say
it's bad it's wrong but it would be the
solution to so many of our problems if
we could just do it
and that's why when i hear about
fracking we see those videos where the
fire is shooting out of the faucet and
stuff
i don't believe it i mean you see the
michael moore documentary that
oh where he said they were all lying
that was crazy i didn't see it but i i
read about it he got roasted yeah
because they
but but yeah yeah i i
worked for greenpeace a decade ago
longer than a decade ago
and i learned about their founders one
of their founders um
i think his name is patrick moore i
might be his name wrong i think he
follows me on twitter now
uh he left a long time ago because and
i'm probably i don't know
i don't want to get a story wrong one of
the reasons is he supports nuclear
energy
and greenpeace doesn't it makes no sense
if you believe in protecting the
environment nuclear energy is a great
way to do it
but i guess they make money off the
boogeyman the specter
of this technology because of things
like chernobyl three mile island
and fukushima fukushima was really bad i
mean but that was a tsunami so i mean
they definitely need to make sure they
have security uh set up to make sure
that doesn't happen again
but i i ended up hearing these stories
i read about this guy i read about
nuclear energy and how the left opposes
it
and i got really confused because it's a
green energy it's new
tech it's extremely good for this
our country and the world but they
oppose it then they come to me and
they come with other stories about
fracking and all these other
you know fossil fuel you know operations
and now i just don't know what to
believe
because i know the nuclear energy stuff
is all exaggerated i mean sure it has
its problems
but then when they come to me and they
claim fracking is the worst thing it
ought to be bad it's to be shut down
immediately overnight
ban all fossil fuels i'm like i don't i
don't know if i believe you man i don't
know i don't know if you're being honest
but i don't know what their endgame is
with banning fossil fuels other than
climate change
but if that were the case would nuclear
energy be the solution yeah well right
correct i'll add one more point the
former chief of staff for aoc straight
up said the green new deal
is more about changing the economy it is
not yeah it's not about
it's it's not about green energy it is
about control
it's about changing the the structure of
our country
right changing the economy that's what
it's about and and you're right
our chief of staff said it thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8 pm if you want to
catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you